dementia effects 850,000 people in the
UK but it's not a disease in itself it's
the name given to a range of symptoms
that affect the brain including memory
loss and difficulties worth thinking
problem-solving or language it has many
different causes but they all result in
the death of brain cells and symptoms
that get worse with time Alzheimer's
disease is the most common form of
dementia with 550,000 people affected in
the UK it's caused by a buildup of
abnormal proteins in the brain the
results in the loss of connections
between nerve cells and ultimately the
death of brain tissue the number of
people in the UK with dementia is
expected to reach 1 million by 2025 and
2 million by 2050 that's largely because
of the aging population dementia
generally affects older people lifestyle
particularly smoking and diet can also
increase the chances of some forms of
dementia it's only recently that the
full impact of dementia on society has
been recognized pushing it up the
political agenda around six hundred and
seventy thousand people currently care
for someone with dementia many will have
given up work to do so and the cost of
dementia to the economy has been put at
26 billion pounds a year the leaders of
the g8 nations have come together to
make dementia a priority with the aim of
finding a medicine to slow or halt the
symptoms by 2025 because it's a
condition of older age just delaying the
symptoms by five years would halve the
number of cases now a drug called solo
nezam AB has been shown to slow the
decline in brain function by 30% if it's
given in the early stages and with a
sharp increase in research funding there
is a feeling that it's only a matter of
time before doctors do have effective
treatment